ucrania cumple hoy su día número 78 de
la guerra con una contraofensiva
ucraniana que continúa y que se siente
particularmente fuerte aquí en heart y
va de hecho en su cráneo sostienen que
ha logrado empujar a los rusos a 10
kilómetros de la frontera y que también
han retomado el control de algunos
pueblos en otros todavía los combates
son a pocos kilómetros de distancia de
hecho se trata de ciudades prácticamente
divididas en esta región donde nos
encontramos y todo esto ocurre mientras
está creciendo una crisis humanitaria en
esta región de ucrania esta mañana nos
hemos despertado con larguísimas colas
de personas a personas que están
buscando abastecerse de comida y de
gasolina un bien que está acá está
escaseando y que incluso está provocando
problemas a los vehículos humanitarios